long story short i can't fish my now
fiance
i grew up in a small town that was super
against the lgbtq plus community i
thought my whole life i had to hide my
sexuality from my family
i printed i pretended to be a guy as i
talked with this girl for a few years as
a female before meeting my now female
fiance
i cannot put into words how much we fell
in love with each other
one year i thought this [ __ ] is too
much and decided to meet her and it was
magical
fast forward years later we are getting
married but i can't shake off what i did
to her
i feel i am responsible for a lot of her
insecurities i mean
am i a [ __ ] person or do i move on or
what wait how did the i don't understand
what
how did the cat fishing happen he
basically acted that
she was a guy the whole time and then
it's a woman it's a lesbian couple
that's engaged yeah they are
females so a woman that pretended she
was a guy yeah and started hitting on
this other girl online
they fell in love they fell in love met
her in person right revealed she was a
woman
and and then the girl was cool with it
she was cool with it but apparently
there's lots of insecurities and it's
almost like this person
we'll call her low she can't shake off
the feeling that she had lied and it's
all based on a lie
yeah but without the lie they would
never be together yeah
i've gotten tricked by a girl that looks
like a boy really
mm-hmm i forgive her yeah
how'd that pound out well she just
looked kind of like a boy i mean i knew
she was a girl but
the fingers got in she creeped on up she
got a couple knuckles in yeah i've never
been catfished
is that is that a bad thing i feel like
now it's hard to catfish but there are
like we see in like
we watch 90 days beyonce yolanda
yeah i mean you once you're past 50 it's
very easy to be
catfished because you're just you don't
know how the internet works and
you know williams you know when when she
remember when she was really after
williams
yeah no and why would there be an s oh
yolanda
i'm here but i'm mad at you
me too it's like [ __ ] it
lock her in a room and i'm being real
it's like mom are you you're your
[ __ ] mind it's so sad
he's not gonna [ __ ] he's not real
haven't you had to do that to your
friends with real boyfriends to where
like he doesn't like you
you just have to people just are so they
want their
their fantasy to be real so bad that
they will just they'll i've lost
friendships over telling people the
truth about where i'm like this person's
disrespecting they're obviously not into
you
and they scream at me and are mad at me
and don't wanna be friends with me
anymore and it's like
do you want the truth or do you wanna
it's like literally the matrix yeah like
do you want yeah
or the blue pill yeah i i've never been
i haven't been there since i was like in
my early 20s
like fallen somebody for the out that
hard have you do you fall people
for people that hard i get anxiously
attached to people sometimes it depends
on
if they like remind me of my mom or dad
honestly it's like it's all childhood
wounds
so it's if the if a guy it gives me a
lot of attention
and i'm not it's usually like people i'm
not that into at first and then i'm like
oh i'll give them a shot
and then the minute i bang them or
something they withdraw then i'm like
wait why don't you love me like don't